let's talk about israel's new friends
for years many arab countries banded
together against israel
but some countries are rethinking that
saudi arabia was actually the first arab
state
to put normalization with israel on the
table prime minister benjamin netanyahu
has made a secret visit to saudi arabia
some are even making it official the
agreement signed between
israel the united arab emirates and
bahrain formalizes relationships already
in place
what they're calling normalization
appears to have been happening
quietly for years now it's out in the
open
and the u.s is pretty much leading the
whole thing so what does
normalization even mean what's in it for
these countries
and how does it affect the palestinians
[Music]
normalization is basically diplomatic
speak for two countries having some kind
of formal relationship
where before there was none through
things like trade deals setting up
embassies and direct flights
but not that long ago the idea of gulf
countries having cordial relations with
israel was
unthinkable there's been a lot of bad
blood
in 1948 israel expelled around 750
000 palestinians and declared itself a
state the conflict catches the
inevitable
innocent in its soil that basically
sparked
decades of on-again off-again
arab-israeli wars
[Music]
at one point saudi arabia even sent in
troops
since then the problem has been how
israel is slowly taking over palestinian
land
by illegally building settlements
blockading the gaza strip
and militarily occupying everything else
so for as long as many can remember
saudi arabia has stood by the
palestinians particularly king salman
together with other arab states the
saudis drew a line in the sand
in 2002. no normalization without an end
to israeli occupation
and agreement on the establishment of a
palestinian state on the 1967 lines
but king salman is not really in charge
anymore and his son
seems to have other ideas the old guard
is anti-israel is pro-palestinian
but now you have a newer generation than
your god he is not very attached
to the palestinian identity it's why
those recent reports of a secret saudi
israeli meeting
got so much attention in a first of its
kind
u.s and israeli media say the american
secretary of state mike pompeo
was on an official visit to saudi arabia
when benjamin netanyahu flew over too
and touched down in hill the saudis
though say it never happened
there's something going on israeli are
excited to go
public in this the americas are excited
before trump
leaves and the saudis seems more let's
take it step by step we have a vision
where
israel becomes a normal part of
the region where it has fully normal
relations with its neighbors
what we need to have that happen is for
a peace deal between the palestinians
and the israelis
other countries are already embracing a
new friendship bahrain and the united
arab emirates both signed deals with
israel in 2020
a golden opportunity for peace security
and prosperity for our region those who
are with us today
and those who will join us tomorrow i
say
assalamu alaikum sudan has a
normalization agreement too
so where does all of this leave the
palestinians
well it weakens their leaders position
to negotiate a peace deal with israel
and for many palestinian people it'll
just be harder to get justice
or undo decades of israeli occupation
the palestinians are saying israel has
been rewarded for conceding nothing
[Applause]
so why the change i think for the
emirati is very clear it's a business
transaction
there was a uae israeli trade conference
and twitter pages are now promoting
israeli products in the gulf
and emirati products in israel
any other year this joint music video by
israeli and emirati artists would have
just seemed weird
but this is 2020. it puts israel in a
different light
it revives the ability to really openly
work and openly trade with these
countries
trading with israel would make business
sense for saudi arabia too
but normalizing with israel is about
more than making money
it's no secret that mbs is trying to
remake his own image
as a modern leader he's got a lot to
overcome
think the war in yemen
arresting critics even accusations he
was involved in the shocking
dismemberment of the journalist jamal
khashoggi
he plans at some point to ascend to
power he plans not to have any
western disapproval of this especially
in washington
so this is big on his mind so for a
smooth ascension to the throne
mbs needs friends in high places
back in 2018 trump and mbs were laughing
it up in the oval office
the occasion was a business tour by
saudi arabia
three billion dollars 525
million dollars that's peanuts for you
under trump it's a relationship that
seems to be able to withstand just about
anything
even after khashoggi's murder trump's
son-in-law and advisor jared kushner
kept in touch with mbs but with joe
biden as u.s president
that relationship is expected to change
it's not going to be any more
what's up messages with the kushner in
the middle of the night it's going to go
back to institutional relations to
going through the embassy going through
the state department but there's still
time for trump and others to influence
the next four years
especially when it comes to iran because
nothing makes friends
quite like having a common enemy they
divert tens of billions of dollars to
their
nuclear program
we will never let that happen
one of the first things trump did in
office was pull out of the nuclear deal
and order more sanctions on iran
but the incoming u.s president says he
wants to revive that deal
that could be why trump seems to be
pushing all these new alliances in the
middle east before biden gets in
i cannot reverse a a saudi israeli deal
if it already happened before he comes
to power it already happened he has to
deal with the new reality
a deal between mbs and netanyahu won't
be an easy
sell to many people in the region
there's already been some resistance to
the deals that were signed before
normalizing ties with israel's arab
neighbors is a big win for netanyahu
saudi arabia would be the top prize for
all of them it's good for business
for some it means isolating iran but for
the palestinians
it's a betrayal
if there's a news story or a topic you
want us to explain on start here get in
touch by leaving a comment wherever
you're watching this video
the best way to keep up with our
episodes is to like follow or subscribe
to al jazeera i'll see you next week
you